here are their participants for the fast and all
fastest skater and you see the odds to your right
McDavid a huge favorite I think that McDavid
if he enters into this and he really puts his
heart into it he puts everything he has into it
I think he's going to win this event I think his
other players obviously they're very fast but he
can carry the momentum in the corners better than
anybody in the league and we've seen that over
and over and over again of course we have data
for top speed and average speed of an NHL game
William nander actually owns the lowest top speed
of this Bunch so he's a big Underdog and here he
goes participant number one for the evening and
participant number one in the fastest skater
competition here he comes down the [Applause]
stretch so William nander finishes his lap the
clock for some reason didn't stop so we'll have
to figure out where it was when he crossed the
line so we we could have our first review of The
Nightmare we're have first you can see when he's
coming around here it's all about being able to
carry the speed through the corners as you can see
him going around there his legs giv out a little
bit of skates his Edge is given out that's costing
him time if you can carry the corners at full
speed and come out of with actually faster than
going into it you got a chance to win this event
you can see right somewhere right there maybe that
wasn't the right one but uh one of the corners he
kind of took a little bit of a stumble there so
we want to get an official time before Hughes
goes so 14164 the time to beat for now
you can choose which direction you go
mess which direction did you go back
my left side going going to the left
was always my better Side Y okay I think for
most lefties it is cuz you carry your stick to
the inside so I think you'll see most of the
left-handers go uh go to the left captain of
the Canucks Quinn Hughes American maid played
college hockey at Michigan for the Wolverine
I don't know what they did to the Hughes boys
there but all three of them are amazing skaters
see if he beats neander he does so he's currently
in first place I think we got to get to the high
12s low 13s to win this event in my opinion well
we step it up now with Ma barzel and McDavid
they're in a little bit different league but of
course last year we saw marar fall in Florida
well that's the thing you it's all in the corners
this event going to win or lose it in the in the
terms so McDavid who is going to go last will
now wait for a couple more skaters let's not
to underestimate how difficult it is for these
players here with not a real proper warmup as
well you think falling Downs on his mind right
now after last year no absolutely not a great
players don't think of those things are behind
them he'll be going left over right look at the
power in that stride right there all right he
makes sure he makes that first turn that is
a strong stride little coasting on the corner
as those was going to cost him oh so hes hangs
on look how close that is K Mar is
now in second [Applause] [Music]
place five points for first four for second three
for third 1,000th of a second Quinn Hughes hangs
on so that that matters as you're trying
to accumulate points with each competition
tonight and we'll keep a running scoreboard for
the folks at home and that's the most exciting
part about it is that everything matters every
little point that you can get scrape out there
could be the difference of winning and losing
in the end Matthew barzel 2020 champ he comes
to closest to McDavid in both top speed and
average speed categories during NHL games
this year and you can see him on that first turn
Flawless through the turn there a little hicup
there in that third corner there but the first
oh that was easy yeah there we go easy peasy
yeah so that's the time McDavid
has to beat so Quinn Hughes does
slot down one but he's guaranteed at
worst third watch him take this first
corner here never stops his feet
moving there accelerates out of
[Applause] it whoa little speed wobble there
so Conor McDavid knows the time to beat that's
going to be a tough that's going to be a tough
score to beat got to watch Connor on these on
the first uh first two turns here McDavid the
odds on favorite he has reached the top speed
of 23.5 eight mph this season his average speed
this is where he excels right look at that that
this just looks different look at his feet
never stop moving never looks different never
stop moving well there's a win winner winner
chicken parm dinner the ability for him to
hold the edges in the corners at top speed is
what separates him from most of the players of
the National Hockey League and that was on
full display right there he grew up in the
Toronto area he did Nick a couple pylons mess
but those things are light didn't affect him
at all didn't affect him fourth win in this
competition most all time you can uh like I
said if he puts his if he puts his heart into
it and he really goes for it I think there's a
faster scared in the National Hockey League
and this is why right here watching his feet
through the corners but being able to hold
the edge at top speed a lot of strength a
lot of skill a lot of practice but Nobody Does
it Better that's going to be a tough time to
beat so there's six primary events in round one
the player picks which four he wants to go in